celebrity fragrance
oh I like it this just smells like a
candy store a 15 year old girl would
wear this to the mall it smells like a
cotton candy poodle this is somebody who
wants me to fall in love with them like
Britney Spears
I vote one direction it has to be
breaking yeah you let you and Britney
this smells like grass clippings and
armpits I smelled drug dealer I would
smell this person all day this is very
girly no this is not a dude scent
this is Tim McGraw boy Jones I'm going
Avril
this is Usher what this is his
confession if he thinks this is what a
lady should smell like I'm gonna defer
to him I took home wait this is for guys
it's like really pretty I'll sure smells
like a 13 year old girl apparently I was
like what what I used to put on in like
limited to I want nothing to do with
this smell this is the gym I would bathe
in this I get to decide a middle school
dance with the arms like this it's like
a bad candy I think it smells like a
five-year-old girl therefore I'd say
it's one direction if it is one
direction they want their girls to smell
like [ __ ] yeah I can do it one
direction for all of your school dance
needs smells like a guy who's like at
the bar and he's like oh I'm gonna order
mojito and hit on all these girls this
reminds me of something my mom used to
wear my mom would wear this
it's like someone you can tell she can't
dance it smells like balls man can I
just keep this in my pocket I love it
I'm gonna go with him okay pitbulls
Adana music he's not gonna have some
gutter Cologne like this it has to be
Usher it's been no pitbulls great
pitbulls got his [ __ ] together
he's like the every woman's man no
haters
that smells like a bath and Bodyworks it
smells like a soaps smells like my
grandma this [ __ ] smells basic it's not
offensive it's just like there's nothing
sexy about this basic wretched [ __ ] I
think it's Kim
I vote Kim I feel like it might be it's
Kim oh [ __ ]
Kanye would not have designed this
though
hey brainy hack hell what are you doing
just making fragrances that smell like a
mall